there's so many things about this film I
think there are striking chords with
different people one of the things is
that there's this amazing fight training
scene early on on the mascara yeah on
the island and you cast a hundred and
fifty women real amazing athletes to
play these Amazons in training and what
struck me about it is they're all
beautiful but in different ways yeah
different body types but they're amazing
they're all amazing athletes and it I
was occurring to me that that was such
an amazing choice because I think in a
previous era maybe with a male director
they would have just gone for a certain
you know type yeah didn't mean like Oh
everyone wants should look on this
island should look like a pretty model
and here they're all beautiful women but
they're amazing athletes and they're
really doing the stunts how did you get
those people it was not easy it was one
of the hardest things about the movie
was thinking about okay this Amazon are
me I'm them scare how are we gonna do
that and what what's interesting about
what you're saying is it's not even like
I care about all these things as well
but it's not even like I went out of my
way to say they have to look at
absolutely different instead I was
saying who who would these women be and
how do I find the most badass women in
the world and you know ultimately it's
like I love beautiful women too but if I
can if you if you're not gonna beat me
in a fistfight like who would that way
that what kind of an Amazon is that so
so you're like if I feel stronger than
them then that's not a good thing so we
set out to finding all the best Amazon
like the most incredible athletes in the
world people like Ann Woolf who's like
held every weight class at the same time
simultaneously for years best boxer in
history female boxer and you know
Madeleine Valle who's an incredible
kickboxer muy Thai and Brooke ence who's
a CrossFit champion just these things
you just started picking out looking all
over the world and finding these
incredible horse riders athletes for the
horse riding so it is a champion horse
rider the flips that the things that
they're doing with the weaponry and on
the horses and you watch it and as as a
guy I thought I wouldn't last a second
yeah with any of these women yeah
which isn't saying a lot
you